For fans of Matt Groening's sci-fi comedy
"Futurama," it may seem like a millennium
has come and gone since we last saw
the Planet Express crew in action.
It's hard to believe that a full 22 years have
passed since the show made its auspicious premiere
on Fox and that it's been eight years since
its bittersweet finale brought it to a close.
The series' fractured run saw it earn a handful
of Emmys, score a fiercely devoted fanbase, and
make a legitimate case for being one of the best
animated series of all time. Regardless, the show
constantly struggled with ratings and was canceled
by Fox after four glorious seasons, only to be
reborn on Comedy Central with the restructured
direct-to-video films. Then, unfortunately,
it was canceled again after an additional two
seasons. Low ratings and cancelations aside,
every step of the way, Groening and company
consistently made "Futurama" that rarest of
animated series — one that could easily make you
laugh out loud or openly weep into the cosmos.
The show's blend of low-brow humor, high-minded
insight, and raw, unabashed emotion is what
helped make "Futurama" a cult hit in its initial
run on Fox. It's also a big reason the series'
storied legacy only grew in syndication, which
ultimately led to its revival on Comedy Central.
And it's why — even after that unexpected
gift of a 60 + episode revival — "Futurama"
fans still clamor for even more cosmic
adventures with the Planet Express gang.
We can't say for sure whether or not another
season of "Futurama" might eventually be on
the horizon. Though, with each passing day,
the prospect of new episodes full of humor,
heart, and random pop culture references seems
about as likely as ridding yourself
of a brain slug of your own free will.
"Hopes deleted."
The only ray of optimism we can offer is that the
cast sounds excited to get back in the spaceship.
Voice actor Maurice LaMarche told Syfy Wire
that the old cast remains in touch and that
they're all ready and willing to head back to
the recording booth should more episodes arise.
He went on to say…
"I have to leave it up to the Powers
That Be, but I know everybody's into it,
including the cast. [...] So hopefully
someday there'll be a 'Futurama' reboot,
but we're well-practiced at the reboot thing."
Since the cast is willing, and now that
Disney acquired 20th Century Studios,
perhaps they will want to revive the show,
seeing how it still has a fervent fan base.
Stranger things have happened,
especially in the world of "Futurama."
"Guess this is your lucky day, Pimparoo."
However, some longtime viewers have
wondered whether we actually need new
episodes of "Futurama." Those fans point
out that all good things do eventually
come to an end — and many of the best things
come to an end a little quicker than most.
That's especially true of
television. Thanks to poor ratings,
some brilliant shows with amazing
potential become history way too
soon. And then there are others that stay
on the air many years past their prime.
"I know what you mean."
Either way, most fans agree that "Futurama"
ended exactly the way it should have back
in 2013. That's due to the fact that
Comedy Central's brass did something
Fox didn't do so many years ago. They gave the
show's creators a heads-up that the end was near.
That inside info allowed the "Futurama"
team to ensure that the series received a
fitting swan song — one that tugged on the
heartstrings as much as it tickled the funny bone.
"Quit touching my junk, pervert!"
The show's finale — simply titled "Meanwhile" —
more than achieved that goal. Groening and company
imbued the episode with all the wit, wonder,
and insight you'd expect from the series, icing
the cake with a ravishingly romantic storyline
rarely seen in the annals of animated television.
As many have pointed out, new
"Futurama" episodes might seem
extraneous in the wake of that finale.
Not just because "Meanwhile" was such
an effective series end, but also because
fond farewells are so rare in an era where
network and streaming executives always
seem to have their axes at the ready.
After all, one of the key narrative threads
throughout the show's largely remarkable 140
episode run was that time is finite. No
matter how many time-shifting devices or
bizarre scenarios you encounter, it's important to
appreciate what you have while you still have it.
"No it isn't! Shut your filthy clam!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.